okay let's compare gke and Cloud run for
containerized workloads a lot is going
to depend on the specifics of your
workload Cloud run works well for web
apps grpc apis or event-based apps while
gke expands to more complex use cases
including ones that require gpus
specific OS config or deeper control
over networking gke gives you far more
control to run a customized platform to
host all your different containers while
cloudrun supports a set of essential
configuration settings and manages the
rest for you gke requires some
operational overhead though autopilot
mode helps while still letting you build
on the kubernetes API and cloudron can
scale automatically based on the number
of incoming requests and even scales to
zero more info pinned in the comments